good morning believe nation today's
message is just go and do it over to you
Pierre Omidyar when you look at the
accomplishments of accomplished people
and you say boy that must have been
really hard you know when you look at
something that looks hard that was
probably easy and conversely when you
look at something that looks easy that
was probably hard and so you're never
going to know which is which until you
actually go and do it so just go and do
it try learn from it you know you'll
fail at some things that's a learning
experience that you need so that you can
take that on to the next experience and
don't let people who you may respect and
who you believe know what they're
talking about don't let them tell you it
can't be done because often they will
tell you it can't be done and it's just
because they don't have the courage to
try it I think too many entrepreneurs
when they're getting started hold
themselves back because you keep asking
yourself what if what if this happens
what if this happens what if this
happens and you think about all the
possible negative consequences that it
freaks you out and then you never
actually get started instead of focusing
on the negative focus on how can you go
out and accomplish that goal and if it's
not your own head telling you what if
sometimes it's the people in your life
right the little man in your life who's
holding you back you saying what if this
what if this what if this and you spend
so much time just focus on that negative
side instead of figuring out what do I
need to do to actually make this happen
when you focus on the how instead of the
what if you're more likely to be
successful so the question they today is
what's holding you back from just going
out and doing it leave in the comments
below I'll join the discussion thank you
so much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
of espresso okay
nespresso give me go